hello everyone here we have another very
exciting game from the pro chesley it
was played on the 4th of February and as
I'm saying in most of my videos how I'm
preparing myself for the Budapest gambit
as I really want to try it out in some
serious games in tournament games I
managed to find one game that was played
like it's a modern game from 2018 where
someone used the Budapest gambit and I
found this game between an international
master from the Czech Republic
Wojtek survived on his playing against a
player from France
haru-chan parsegian and per second here
doesn't have any titles but he's his
national rating is somewhere around
twenty four seventy so definitely a
strong player and I was very excited to
see the budapest gambit played at such a
strong level so Wojtek opened with d4 we
have Knight to f6 c4 and now the move
that signifies the budapest gambit d5 as
they say the best way to refugio gambit
is to accept it Saudi captures only five
any other move really only favours black
Saudi captures only five and now Knight
to g4 the knight is very annoying on g4
also black is immediately threatening to
capture on e5 winning back the pawn so
here we have Bishop to f4 another idea
white can employees defend with Knight
to f3
but then he allows black to go d6 to go
into it into another line of this gambit
which he captures on d6 and Bishop
captures sorry and Bishop captures on d6
but when you meet someone who plays the
budapest gambit of course you know he's
prepared for this so you don't want to
allow this so after 9g for Bishop
terraform was played and now g5 it's the
main idea where I wonder why decides to
defend the pawn with a Bishop to f4
Bishop to g3 and now Bishop to g7 so Oh
No why does have a small edge he's up
upon although it's a double pawn but you
know you have to play correctly
Knight to f3 and we have Knight to c6
again going for that ePHI pawn and here
Knight to c3 black captures the pawn
back Knight captures we have Knight
captures Knight captures and now III
d6 by black and now h4 as black already
compromised his King side position white
wants to break open here and have an
open H file for his rope okay send me
open H file but it would be nice to have
that black blocks the position with the
g4 and now this is a pretty solid set
setup for black he has a very strong
knight on e5 you can't really get rid of
it unless you want to give up your
bishop for a knight
which leaves black wood the bishop pair
you can push f4 because of Gigi afters
on f3 on Poisson and all in all that g4
point is very well protected by the
knight on e5 and the bishop on c8 here
at white pushes h5 he wants to push h6
and a black plays h6 himself and not
allowing h6 by white Bishop to e2 now
Bishop to e6 attacking the c4 pawn also
developing a piece rough to c1 and here
we have Queen to d7 you don't want to
capture upon here if you play Knight
captures on c4 white can't win a piece
by Queen to a4 check as Queen to d7
defense both both threats as the bishop
is still defending the knight on c4 but
this fall's the Bishop captures on c4
and after Bishop captures now Queen
captures attacking the bishop on g7 and
the bishop on c4 after Bishop captures
on c3 would check rook captures now
after the bishop retreats let's say
Bishop to e6 now comes Queen to g7 and
blacks position is just terrible here
so after this rook to see one black
decided to play Queen to d7 and here we
have b3 now defending that pawn on c4
black wait queenside castle and here we
have Knight to d5 f 5 we have Knight to
f4 I'm going for the bishop on e6 Bishop
to f7
now this you you again you can see this
very nice correlation between a bishop
and a knight the bishop is controlling
all the squares the knight can jump -
sorry here we have a link to d2 and now
came to b8 Bishop to h4 attacking the
rook rook to e8 and now castles we have
rook eat the g8 and here
roof after the
a better move would be something like
Ruth to g3 or Queen to c2 but you'll see
why in a minute
right after d1 was played and here why
black immediately played Knight to f3
check now as your queen is forked now
there is check you have to accept this
so Bishop captures on f3 we have G
captures on f3 and now g3 as you don't
want to capture that pawn as well if you
capture it then comes Bishop to c3 with
check you lose the Queen so Bishop to e5
now preparing to grab the night on f4
also when white pushes c5 this d6 pawn
will be defended so c5 you me
immediately buy white and now comes roof
to g4 black wants the double-up rooks
and the G file and there he will have a
lot of threats here Queen to b4 was
played and it was at this moment when
this Queen to b4 was played that black
successfully mounted his attack this
this was like the point of no return for
white but here instead of going to
before White has to play something like
Knight to b3 to attack the bishop here
and the threat of course is capturing
the bishop and then after pawn captures
you lose the Queen so after something
like Queen to see it now captures
captures and after Queen to d7 it seems
a white managed to block blacks attack
after Bishop captures you can even push
c6 and white retains a small edge here
in this position but after this rock to
g4 move we said that tonight to d3 was
the better idea white played Queen to b4
with ideas of pushing c6 some Queen to
f4 Queen to a6 and maybe some checkmate
ideas on b7 here rook H the g8 was
played now doubling up on the G file the
threat of course is rook captures Bishop
as now the pawn is pinned
we have c6 of course you can't capture
here and the only you only move you can
play is actually Queen to c8 because you
don't want to get checkmate and um be 7
so Queen to see 8 and now we have King
to f1 on pinning so now it seems like
black can capture the bishop but here we
have
v6 and Queen to a4 if that Queen ever
moves then Queen to a6 will be a very
dangerous idea and here black takes
advantage of the Queen being on the
fourth-ranked and plays Bishop captures
on h5 now of course you can't capture
the bishop because your queen is hanging
the rook is on g4 x-raying that Queen
and here we have before trying to stop
this idea now now white can capture the
bishop on h5 but this was actually the
last the last good moment for white to
play something like rook to c2 to create
an escape route for his king but okay
instead of rook to c2 he played before
now with the idea of capturing the
bishop but now comes Bishop captures we
have F captures and now comes Luke
captures on h4 was the idea behind rook
captures on h4 well you'll see in a
second
white replied G captures on h4 there
really isn't a better move here and now
comes Queen to e6 what the terrible
threat does Queen 2 e 2 and this will be
checkmate unfortunately you can't defend
this with playing something like ruff do
you want because rook to e1 falls to
another checkmate
if rock do you want then rook to g1
check King captures and now Queen to g6
and whatever white plays is checkmate
you have King f1 king h1 and King h2
whatever white plays its Queen to G 2
and this will be checkmate King F 1 into
G to checkmate so here after Queen to b6
of course you cannot defend with rook to
e1 so White's right look to c2 now but
now as rook to c2 does defend against
this threat as the King will have an
escape route here it's too late for rook
to c2 now because now black has another
winning move and ok III think this is a
pretty decent position for you to pause
the video and find a winning move that
there are actually two winning moves but
one is one is the more forcing so to try
to find that one but in any move you
find out of these two will be fine so I
do hope you pause the video and to those
of you who were able to solve this
congratulations you're a great player
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show
the move black plate here was actually
Queen 2e to check giving up a queen but
this is only temporarily they had
removed that wins is actually Bishop to
g4 the threat is the instant Bishop to
h3 checkmate if you found this you're a
great player as well but in the game
Queen to e2 check was played no you
don't really have any options here you
have to capture the Queen rook captures
and here pawn captures with check as you
can see the bishop is still protecting
the pawn I need to only move as king do
you want and here we have roof did you
want check and it was in this position
that Internet the the check
International Master avoids London
resigned the game what would follow is
King to e2 only move and now Peter rook
captures or Queen captures with check if
you move the King you lose the Queen and
a4 and after you take the Queen now
comes row capture some d1 and at the end
of this lovely skirmish a black is up a
rook and the bishop so what a better
game to show you how the Budapest gambit
works now as in all gambits white always
has a slight edge if he plays correctly
but if he doesn't play correctly this is
this is a the kind of final position you
could get in your own games if you enjoy
playing an occasional gambit so yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
I would like to think there's Sergio
Garcia for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot - really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thankful for
watching and I will see you soon and I
am still taking suggestions what do you
want for the giveaway price after my
channel reaches 100,000 subscribers
thank you and I will see you soon